Hi, I’m Sam Schultz.
I’m new here on Journey to the Microcosmos
and I’ve been put up to a very questionable
task for my first episode.
While the other new hosts get to talk about
beautiful microbes like the Beggiatoa, I am
here to talk to you about butts.
A whole compilation of them.
And I know why I’ve been
asked to do this.
I’m a producer for SciShow and one of the
hosts for the lightly competitive science
game show podcast SciShow Tangents.
And each of our episodes ends with a butt
fact, where one of our panelists recites a
fact about butts or poop or something
vaguely butt-related.
We’ve also been known to argue about important
existential questions that can shake you to
your very core, like…is butt legs?
But as someone who is on Team “Butt is Legs,”
I have to admit that microbes make a compelling
argument for the opposition, because so many
of them don’t have legs but still have a butt.
Like in this first video, about the flowery-looking
animal called Bryozoa.
When you first see them, you’ll probably
be like, “Wait, where’s the butt?”
But stick around, and you’ll find out why
that’s actually a very important question
for scientists studying the Bryozoa.
If I were to ask you to just do a little sketch
of what you think of when you hear the phrase
“moss animals,” you might imagine something
like this tardigrade—a waddling, slightly
fantastical creature that we did in fact find
living within the minuscule greenery of moss.
But depending on who you
are and what you know,
maybe you draw something completely different.
Maybe you draw something more like this.
These don’t really look much like an animal
at all, do they?
At first glance, they seem a bit more like
plants, with a stalk connecting a series of
flowers with thin, elegant petals.
But no, that is indeed an animal.
One that has the dubious honor of being defined
largely by its anus.
Before we get there though, let’s start with just
explaining what these animals actually are.
These organisms are members of the phylum
Bryozoa, a name that translates in Greek to
“moss animals”.
But Bryozoa aren’t actually animals that
live in moss.
They get their name because of what they look
like when all of the elegant individuals you
see here congregate into colonies that look,
ya know, mossy.
That giant gelatinous mass seems to bear little
resemblance to the tiny winsome creatures
that make it up.
But Bryozoa are notable in the animal kingdom
because of just how colonial the phyla is.
Around the world, in waters salty and not,
are colonies of different shapes and sizes
made up of individuals like these.
These colonies can get their start in different
ways.
Some might be the result of sexual reproduction,
sperm and egg that could have met in the waters
away from their makers.
Or, in other cases, one colony may have captured
sperm released by another, using it to fertilize
its own eggs, which stay brooding until a
larva emerges, ready to set out and develop
its own colony.
But Bryozoa have another asexual option for
reproduction.
Instead of fertilizing an egg, a colony can
amass a bunch of cells into a structure like
this one, called a statoblast.
These statoblasts can be so prevalent in our
samples that James, our master of microscopes,
has to scoop them out to keep them from being
the main focus of our videos.
They are thick and durable, able to lay dormant
and protect their contents from cold temperatures
and dry weather.
But when the conditions become right again,
they grow into a new individual that will
form the basis of a new colony.
To do that, the individual Bryozoa, called
a zooid, navigates the waters as a larva,
eventually attaching itself to some kind of
solid surface.
Perhaps a piece of rock, or some kind of shelf,
maybe even some seaweed.
And from there, it will begin to divide, budding
off but keeping its descendants close and
connected as they increase in number.
Now, the arrangement of these zooids dictates
the shape of their colony, as does the material
they secrete to support the colony overall.
Some excrete a gelatinous material that turns
them into those masses of jelly we saw earlier.
Others rely on chitinous materials that give
them more rigidity.
And as they spread over their surface and
even grow up into the water around them, Bryozoa
colonies take on many spectacular shapes.
Even though Bryozoa are different from coral,
they definitely look similar.
And like coral, Bryozoa colonies don’t move.
Instead they remain attached to their surface.
But while they may not be able to move through
the world around them to gather resources,
Bryozoa are able to make the most of their
surroundings, with individual zooids taking
on special functions that allow the group
to accomplish more than the individuals.
Some focus on making eggs, while others form
small beaks that allow them to snap at predators.
And these zooids are all dependent on another
group of zooids that gather food and share
the nutrients with everyone else.
To get that food, the feeding zooids rely
on the lophophore, the ring of tentacles crowning
every zooid’s bodies that looks a bit like
a bunch of thin petals or a very elegant duster.
Those tentacles are covered in cilia, which
circulate the waters around the Bryozoa, stirring
currents like the ones you see here so that
it can sweep bits of food like plankton towards
the animal’s mouth.
And from certain angles, you can see how the
lophophore and the rest of the zooid’s organs
tuck into a sort of casing, which is a structure
called the cystid.
And while the Bryozoa has various other parts
that we could talk about, what we’re really
here for is the anus, which is a much bigger
deal than you might expect from an animal
with such a simple digestive system.
There’s a mouth, an esophagus, and then
a u-shaped gut that leads to the anus.
Now the issue is really rooted in the existential
crisis at the heart of microcosmos: how are
things related to each other?
And what does that mean for the names that
we give to things?
Organisms like these were originally given
the name Polyzoa in 1830, but that was changed
a year later to Bryozoa by the German naturalist
Christian Ehrenberg.
But as more organisms were added to the group,
the people watching them and describing them
realized that they were actually lumping together
two very similar groups of organisms that
actually had some key differences between
them.
And one of those key differences was where
the organism’s anus was located.
One group had their anus situated just outside
their lophophore—that tentacle crown we
were watching gather food earlier.
And one had their anus situated just inside
their lophophore.
So to differentiate between the two groups,
scientists gave them very appropriate names.
One group was called Ectoprocta, which translates
in Ancient Greek to “outside anus”.
And the other were called Entoprocta, which
means “inside anus.”
Because you can define anything by its butt,
as long as you turn to ancient languages.
In general, Bryozoa typically refers to the
Ectoprocts, though for many reasons (..I can’t
possibly imagine why…), Bryozoa seems to
be the preferred name.
But the history and relationship between the
Ectoprocts and Entoprocts remains an ongoing
mystery that scientists continue to explore.
They are not the only creature out there
to be wrapped up in a phylogenetic mystery.
But isn’t it great to know, especially for
such a strange animal like this, that the
mystery is built on butts?
Imagine if your name translated to “inside
anus” or “outside anus”?
I guess it sounds better in Ancient Greek,
but still, scientists really make a lot of
strange choices.
Like the subject of our next video: Antoni
Von Leeuwenhoek, the original master of microscopes.
Leeuwenhoek looked for microbes in all sorts
of interesting places.
But given the subject of our video today,
I think you can figure out one of the more
unique sources of microbial
delights that Leeuwenhoek found.
In the year 1675, I discovered very small
living creatures in rain water, which had
stood but few days in a new earthen pot glazed
blue within.
Those are the famous words that Antony Van
Leeuwenhoek used to describe microbes.
Though he didn’t use the word “microbe”, he
called them animalcules, and the letter itself
is not exactly the one he wrote.
Leeuwenhoek’s version was written, of course,
in Dutch and then sent off to Henry Oldenburg,
the secretary of the Royal Society in London
who founded the publication
Philosophical Transactions.
Oldenberg translated Leeuwenhoek’s work
into English and published it in 1677.
The rest, as they say, is microbiology.
In 1932, the scientist Clifford Dobell published
a biography of Leeuwenhoek called “Antony
van Leeuwenhoek and his “Little animals,”.
Dobell introduces his subject with some self-consciousness
for taking on the story of someone who, if
you’ve been interested in microscopy, you
have almost certainly heard of.
And he wrote:
Dear reader: I know full well that you and
everyone else must have met Mr van Leeuwenhoek
many a time before; but please let me reintroduce
him to you, for he is a man worth knowing
more intimately.
Though he was born exactly 300 years ago he
is still very much alive, and would be glad
to make your better acquaintance—provided
only that you are a “true lover of learning”
(as of course you are).
The fascination with Leeunwenhoek’s work
for Dobell and so many of us lies in the scope
of Leeuwenhoek’s curiosity, and the writing that
documented his many journeys into the microcosmos.
Born in the Netherlands in 1632, Leeuwenhoek
was a draper by trade, meaning that he sold cloth.
He took up microscopy as a hobby, learning
to grind lenses and turn them into a tool
to see into tiny worlds.
The simple microscopes he built were better
than many of those of his contemporaries,
producing images that were both more magnified
and more clear.
Those of course compared to what the average
high school biology class has today, they
were very bad at both of those things.
The creatures Leeuwenhoek described in his
1677 publication were not his first description
of tiny animals in water though.
In 1674, he wrote of “green streaks, spirally
wound,” a description that later observers
have taken to refer to the filamentous green
algae spirogyra.
He also wrote of little creatures he’d found
that were, as he described them, “a thousand
times smaller than the smallest ones I have
ever yet seen upon the rind of cheese.”
Those little cheese rind creatures he was
describing were likely mites.
Reading Leeuwenhoek’s work is kind of like
following an old treasure map.
His words lay out pathways and clues that help
us navigate through a drop of 17th century water.
And if you follow that map, at the end you
find a wealth of information, the knowledge
of microbes and their identities that was
still unknown in his time, but that in the
centuries since has been accumulated.
For Dobell, Leeuwenhoek’s 20th century scientist
biographer, this treasure hunt was a long
one, borne out of his own enchantment with
these original discoveries and a desire to
better understand them.
He learned Dutch, only to find that the 17th
century Dutch of Leeuwenhoek’s letters was
impenetrable to him And with World War I raging
around him, he had to set aside his attempts
to translate Leeuwenhoek’s work for some
time.
But eventually, through what seems to be largely
a lot of determination, Dobell was able to
work his way through Leeuwenhoek’s letters.
And that labor of love led, naturally, to
translating things like Leeuwenhoek’s descriptions
of his own poop.
Per Dobell, Leeuwenhoek wrote the following:
I have usually of a morning a well-formed
stool; but hitherto I have had sometimes a
looseness of the bowels.
[…] My excrement being so thin, I was at
divers times constrained to examine it.
But Leeuwenhoek wasn’t documenting his stool
just for the sake of it.
In that sample, he saw an opportunity to observe
the animals within.
I have at times seen very prettily moving
animalcules […] Their bodies were somewhat
longer than broad, and their belly, which
was flattened, provided with several feet,
with which they made such a movement through
the clear medium and the globules that we
might fancy we saw a pissabed running up against
a wall.
That description sounds promising, but Dobell
had a problem.
Leeuwenhoek had compared his microbes to a
“pissabed,” and like us, Dobell had no
idea what a “pissabed” is.
Even the original English translation he’d
read shrugged it off as a Dutch term with
no obvious English equivalent.
Dobell had to find a 17th century Dutch-English
dictionary to figure out that a “pissabed”
is a woodlouse.
And with that reference point, Dobell had enough
to diagnose Leeuwenhoek—very belatedly,
of course—with Giardia, the product of a
flagellate known as Giardia intestinalis.
At the time that Leeuwenhoek was identifying
the microbial residents of his stool, he almost
certainly didn’t know their role in his
poor digestion.
Nor did he of course have any name for them, or
any of the other microbes that we now know he saw.
And yet we can identify rotifers from his
characterization of their wheeled heads, and
vorticella from his description of their belled
bodies.
The irony of our centuries-later fascination
with reconstructing and replicating Leeuwenhoek’s
work is that his contemporaries had a much
harder time of it.
Leeuwenhoek didn’t help his cause much,
refusing to provide extensive details of his
methods and even keeping his microscope-building
techniques to himself.
He did, however, provide eight signed testimonies
from various men, including a minister, to
verify that he had made these observations.
Of course, signed testimony is one thing.
Reproducibility is another.
Several of Leeuwenhoek’s contemporaries
tried and failed to replicate his observations
until finally Robert Hooke—the famed microscopist
and writer-slash-illustrator of Micrographia—was
able to see the tiny animalcules Leeuwenhoek
had seen.
Hooke however was willing to outline his specific
methods and demonstrate them, validating the
observations Leeuwenhoek had made and providing
others with the means to make their own microbial ventures.
And like Dobell centuries later, Hooke was
reportedly so taken with Leeuwenhoek’s work
that he learned Dutch to read his letters.
The legacy of Leeuwenhoek is in the microbes
he uncovered, but of course it was more than that.
It was also the curiosity that he passed on,
and the acts of interpretation that they inspired—both
literally with all of these scientists taking
up Dutch to just learn from his letters, and
then scientifically as we decipher what microbes
he must have seen.
And so it seems fitting to close with how
Leeuwenhoek viewed his own little animalcules.
He said, “Among all the marvels
that I have discovered in nature,
these are the most marvelous of all.”
I know I’m supposed to think it’s gross that
Leeuwenhoek dug into his own poop for microbes.
But as weird as it is, I also respect the
dedication to his craft.
But now I want to know how many other noted scientists
have documented and studied their poop so
thoroughly that future historians can diagnose
them with an intestine parasite.
Is it just Leeuwenhoek, making him a true
legend?
Well, I’ve probably spent too much time
already thinking about Leeuwenhoek’s butt.
Which brings me to my next question.
What’s the big deal about butts anyway?
Why do we really need them?
Luckily there’s an animal that can
teach us that:
flatworms, a worm so simple that
it doesn’t have an anus.
There are no ghosts in the microcosmos.
There is no Halloween in the microcosmos.
But if there were, this flatworm would fit
in quite nicely with its spectral appearance.
It might be navigating its way through a field
of other organisms, but it looks like it had
three minutes to prepare for a costume party
and decided to go with the classic “old
bedsheet with eyeholes” ghost costume.
And maybe comparing this flatworm (or even
worms in general) to a ghost is kind of apt.
Ghosts straddle two worlds, and so do worms,
though in their case, instead of bridging
the realm of the living and dead, worms manage
to stretch between the micro and the macro.
This creature you’re watching now would
probably be difficult to see without a microscope.
But on the other end, there are worms that
are meters too long to observe with a microscope.
And akin to ghosts, worms might seem like
a sort of reduced form of life.
After all, for a lot of us, worms are the
wiggly tubes that we dug up from playgrounds.
And of all of the worms, flatworms are perhaps
the most simple of all.
But even digging into what it means to be
the simplest worm makes the whole notion of
simplicity seem ludicrous.
So let’s start with the broader question:
what are worms, other than wiggly, self-mating tubes?
While we generally use the word “worm”
to describe many different, unrelated, invertebrate,
tubular animals that belong to a number of
different phyla, there are three main phyla
that people focus on.
The first are our flatworm buddies here, who
are known more formally as Platyhelminthes.
Then there is the phylum Nematoda, known less
formally as roundworms.
We’ve come across nematodes many times in
our journey through the microcosmos, which
makes sense given that they are one of the
most abundant animals on this planet.
And last are the Annelida, phylum of our playground
friend, the earthworm.
While earthworms are a bit beyond the scope
of the micro, if you will, we’ve also got
this little Stylaria lacustris.
At the tip of its head is the proboscis, an
antenna-like structure that the worm uses
for feeding.
And as we scan past the head, you can see
that the length of the Stylaria’s body is segmented.
Of the three phyla we’ve mentioned, annelids
are the most complex.
They have a closed circulatory system with
tubes that transport nutrients and oxygen
throughout their body, as well as a complete
digestive system that has both a mouth to
take in food and an anus to get rid of waste.
If we think of worms in general as a gut enclosed
within a body wall, then that gut is a tube
and the body is a tube, and you can imagine
that worms are a tube inside a tube.
Now what separates these different groups
is the space that separates one of those tubes
from the other.
Complex systems inside annelids are due to
what’s called a coelom, a tissue-lined cavity
that sits between the tube of the digestive
tract and the tube of the body wall.
Importantly, this cavity is filled with fluid,
which facilitates the development of organs
along with the transport of nutrients around
the body.
The development of the first coelom was a
very big deal because coeloms don’t just
allow annelids to have complex systems.
They connect the seemingly simple organisms
we’re talking about here to more complex
animals—like us!
Because annelids and humans are both what
is known as coelomates, or eucoelomates.
We are animals that have coeloms.
So, thank you to the ancestor that we share
with earthworms who developed the first coelom,
who allowed more complex organisms like you
to exist.
Nematodes, on the other hand, are what are
called pseudocoelomates.
They still have a coelom-like fluid-filled
cavity, but the cavity isn’t lined with
tissue like you find in true coeloms.
Other microscopic pseudocoelomates include
gastrotrichs and rotifers.
This pseudocoelom is a slight but significant
difference in nematodes when compared to annelids,
corresponding to a slightly less complex body
plan, though nematodes
still do have a complete digestive system.
The flatworms are the simplest of all.
Starting with the coelom: flatworms don’t
actually have one.
They are considered acoelomates.
That area between the gut and body wall where
annelids and nematodes have a cavity full
of fluid is instead full of tissue.
This has a few consequences for the flatworm,
but one of the biggest ones is that this area
can’t support the development of specialized
systems that you see in other animals.
The lack of coelom imposes limits on the flatworm’s
body and lifestyle, reducing both its complexity
and size.
But that does not mean the flatworm lives
a simple life.
Of the three worm groups, flatworms are the
most like a tube within another tube, except
that their outer tube is much less cylindrical.
The “flat” in “flatworm” is actually
an adaptation: without a circulatory system
or respiratory system, the worm relies on
diffusion across its outer membrane to supply
cells with oxygen.
Being flatter gets the cells closer to the
outside and better positioned for diffusion.
And without the ability to build a complete
digestive system like those found in nematodes
and annelids, flatworms have to adjust to
life without that most under-appreciated body
part of all: the anus.
They take in food through one opening, digest
it in their gut, and then spew the waste back
out from that same opening.
So unlike other organisms who have separate
entrances and exits for their food, the flatworm
must wait to finish digesting before it can
eat again.
But this is not the only way flatworms can
get rid of waste.
Their body is lined with a special type of
cell called a flame cell that also gets waste
out of the worm.
While it may not have the elegance of an interconnected
set of organs, this system is its own form
of complexity.
Basically, every flame cell is one single-celled
kidney, allowing the worm to just...
ooze waste from its skin.
And this is just scratching the surface of the
biological intricacy flatworms are capable of.
Like many of their more involved worm counterparts,
flatworms can reproduce both asexually and sexually.
And when reproducing sexually, they can mate
with another flatworm, or even with themselves--both
making and fertilizing their own eggs.
There’s also those flatworm species that
can regenerate, a trick that our more developed
bodies are, alas, not capable of.
Even the many weird ways they move make the
word “wiggle” feel reductive.
Our perception of simplicity across nature
is built on comparisons.
Compared to us, an earthworm may seem simple.
Put that earthworm next to a flatworm, and
suddenly the earthworm represents a gigantic
biological advancement.
But then put that flatworm next to a bacteria,
and suddenly it contains multitudes, it is a universe.
That flatworm is a marvel, an almost unbelievable
testament to the power of evolution.
I never really thought about how hard it would
be to eat if I had to poop out my mouth at
the same time, but yeah, I guess I have a
newfound appreciation for the fact that our
bodies are equipped with an easy exit strategy
for waste.
But you know who I wish would poop a little
less?
The subject of our next video.
Because now I can’t help but look around
my house and wonder how much of it is covered
in their poop.
One of the most frequent questions we get
asked on Journey to the Microcosmos is how
James, our master of microscopes, stays safe
while gathering and studying samples.
After all, as beautiful as the microcosmos
is, there are plenty of parasites and pathogens
in there that we’d prefer to keep under
the microscope and out of our bodies.
But while James has simple and effective guidelines
to protect his health—like making sure he
always washes his hands before and after handling
samples, and never venturing into a pond with
an open wound—there are times when those
measures don’t quite cut it.
These are the times when no matter how much
you protect yourself outside or inside, the
microcosmos gets the best of you.
These are the times of the dust mite.
Now we don’t usually start these videos
with a warning, but we’re going to do that today.
While working on this video, at least 4 members
of the Journey to the Microcosmos team found
themselves having a bit of a crisis about
how clean their homes were.
If you’ve found yourself sneezing and wheezing
and running around miserable with a runny
nose because of dust, this arachnid is probably
the culprit—though perhaps not in the way
you would expect.
Dust mites are small in the grand scheme of
things, but large in the microcosmos, hitting
just around 300 micrometers in length.
Their bodies are decked out with four pairs
of legs ending in feet that act like suction
cups as they wander in their quest for three
things: water, food, and darkness.
Dust mites love humidity because their lives
depend on it.
They don’t drink water so much as they osmosis
it into them, relying on a salt-filled gland
near their mouth to absorb water vapor from
the air around them.
So if their surroundings become more arid,
an adult dust mite will wither away until
it eventually dies.
This is a challenge for dust mites that live
in places with seasons, where wet and rainy
falls give way to dry winters.
To survive those shifts, they rely on the
resilience of their younger brethren—the
nymphs—whose forms are able to withstand
the lack of moisture.
The seasons of the dust mite’s life was
one of the important clues that helped scientists
in the 20th century understand their role
in dust allergies.
Scientists identified dust as the source of
some kind of allergen in the 1920s, but they
were not sure what it was exactly about dust
that did it.
They just knew that people all over the globe
suffered from dust allergies, and that these
allergies were often seasonal, peaking in
the autumn, particularly after warm, humid summers.
And other possible sources, like animal dander
or mold, just didn’t quite fit right with
the seasonality of the allergy.
But in the 1960s, scientists in the Netherlands
and Japan realized that the dust mite might
be the culprit.
They’re found in large numbers in the dust
that lines the unwashed and untouched corners
of our homes, their populations peaking in
time with the runny noses and bleary eyes
of dust allergies.
But while experiments confirmed that mites
really were the source of people’s sensitivities
to house dust, it wasn’t clear what made
them so special.
So, we’ll get to that in a bit...
James often finds dust mites in the humidity
chambers he uses to keep his microbes alive.
These chambers are made up of a dish lined
with wet toilet paper, which is just about
all a dust mite needs to feel right at home—especially
when there’s potentially some delicious
microbes to munch on.
So to keep those other microbes from becoming
a mite meal, James has to regularly clean
out and disinfect the humidity chamber.
Now, that cleaning might get rid of the dust
mites in the humidity chamber, but the problem
is that our houses are full of food for them
because our houses are full of us—of flakes
from our skin that shed and gather all around
and sustain the invisible mite.
And this is a problem not just because it
means the mite can thrive in our homes.
It’s a problem because food means poop.
Over the course of its life, a mite will produce
about 1000 pieces of poop that are roughly
the size of a grain of pollen.
Inside those bits of fecal matter are enzymes
that help the dust mite eat its own poop and
get nutrients that it might not have gotten
the first time around.
But should the dust mite choose to not revisit
its prior meals, the feces will float around
the room, attached to other particles until
eventually they settle down—perhaps on a
pillow, or on a pet’s bed, or a car seat.
It’s like we’re living in a gigantic snow
globe, except that the snow... is dust mite feces.
In 1981, researchers confirmed the bad news
about this animal’s poop— people are allergic to it.
To be more specific, they confirmed that dust
mite poop contains specific proteins that
many people are allergic to.
So if you’re airing out some sheets and
you start sneezing, what you might actually
be reacting to is dust mite feces flying around
the air.
Now, we apologize for this mental image but
it is reality, and it has embedded in our
heads, so we have to share it with you as
well.
But we can offer what might be a small comfort:
there is another allergen from dust mites
that has nothing to do with poop.
Dust mites have a fairly lengthy mating process,
sometimes taking up to two days to finish—this
is a pretty lengthy time for any organism,
but especially for an animal that’s only
got about 100 total days to live.
Over the course of their life, the female
dust mite will lay up to 80 eggs, which hatch
into larvae that then go through several different
stages of development before becoming adults
With each passing stage, the dust mite sheds
its exoskeleton, leaving behind its youth.
And that exoskeleton provides some of the
other allergens for people react to.
But though that is something people are sometimes
allergic to, it really is mostly just the
poop that sets off people’s allergies.
So I guess there really wasn’t that much
comfort there after all.
And even for a trained and cautious microbiologist,
dust mites can become an unwelcome surprise.
Once, James brought home some samples taken
from a water dish that his neighbor left outside
for their cat.
The surface was covered in tiny round things,
and James thought they might be rotifers.
But when he looked at the surface of the scum
under the microscope, there were no charming
rotifers to be found.
It was mites, just hundreds of them crawling
around the slide.
It was so unpleasant that James immediately
bleached the slide.
Now, he’s not sure if that sample is the
reason, but for days after, James kept sneezing
and having to deal with a runny nose, all
of which pointed to a potential mite invasion.
Fortunately though, our homes are not a utopia
for dust mites.
What they really need is dark, which is why
they prefer to dig themselves deep into carpets
and other soft things that give them space
to burrow4.
Dust mites have a harder time with materials
like suede that are difficult to hide themselves
in, and they usually avoid hard surfaces
that are exposed to light.
So for James, his weapons against the mite
invasion were clear: a vacuum, a mattress
cleaner, and a strong UV light bulb.
It is one of the more ignoble ends to one
of our organisms.
We don’t like to hurt them, unless they
are hurting us.
But I am sure there’s a dust mite somewhere
in our homes right now, settling into a soft,
dark abode of its own, with hardly a care
in the world for the battle that was waged
to bring you this video.
I don’t know what’s grosser.
The idea of eating and pooping out of the
same hole, or the fact that I’m constantly
inhaling dust mite poop.
So let’s end on a happier note,
a festival of feces, if you will, unfolding
in the diverse strategies used by both single-celled
and multicellular organisms to get rid of
their waste.
Ah, food, one of life’s great pleasures.
Whether you’re an organism whose body can
create its own food, or you make do with the
consumption of other organisms, food sustains
and connects life both large and small.
But we’re not going to talk about food today.
We’re going to talk about what happens…after.
No great meal comes without consequences.
Even photosynthetic microbes produce oxygen
they don’t need, a byproduct that is quite
useful to many other organisms, including
us.
And for organisms that have to digest their
food to extract nutrients, well, there’s
all sorts of stuff left behind when the process
is done.
In the world of the microcosmos, there are
not only many varied tiny organisms.
There are also many varied ways to produce
even tinier poop.
And when we say “tinier,” we mean it.
If you’re worried about being grossed out
by this video, or you really want to make
sure you’re not missing anything, just know
that some of this pooping will require you
to pay very close attention.
Some of this will probably look similar to
macroscopic bowel movements, and some will
seem less so.
So let’s start with the more poop-like poop
that comes from some of the multicellular
members of the microcosmos, particularly the
ones with digestive systems complete with
specialized regions for digesting food and
releasing solid waste.
Our dragon-like friend the gastrotrich is
doing the old scrunch-and-poop, probably after
having finished a nice meal made up of bacteria
or protozoa.
The food came in through its pharynx and was
then sent through the intestine, a straight
tube full of digestive cells.
After, the remains continued their way to
the end of the tube, where lies the anus--a
microscopic gateway out of the gastrotrich
and into the world.
That’s all well and good for the more complex
organisms, but how does one poop when one
does not have a butthole?
Well, for some single-celled organisms, one
becomes the butthole.
Such is the case for amoebas.
Their formlessness allows them to easily shift
their shape around to take in food via phagocytosis.
The amoeba here happens to have found a nice
meal made of a ciliate, which is now contained
in a food vacuole filling with digestive enzymes.
Those enzymes will eventually break the ciliate
down, allowing the amoeba to absorb nutrients
into its cytoplasm.
But then what happens with the remains?
Well, as we see with this amoeba here, it
gets released.
Amoebas and other similar organisms use a
process called exocytosis to send waste back
to the membrane where it is removed from their
body.
You can see this again here in this Mastigamoeba,
slowly gliding along the microscope slide
while a round bit seems to come off up top.
It almost looks like it’s leaving behind
a little piece of itself, which I mean, maybe it is.
Ciliates have a more refined approach to pooping,
which is to say they have the unicellular
equivalent of an anus called the cytoproct.
Ciliates gather food into an oral groove,
and then consume it in the digestive vacuoles
that travel through the cell.
Eventually, when the vacuole makes its way
to the cytoproct, the contents get out, and
there you have ciliate poop.
The way organisms poop—the way microbes
poop—are even more varied and wonderful
than we’ve been able to show you here.
But you might be wondering how you even get
from something relatively simple like this
ciliate releasing a small bit of waste to
something more complex, like this tardigrade
with its more compartmentalized approach to
defecation.
Well the answer, of course, is evolution,
but it’s an answer that leads to many more
unanswered questions.
Even within animals, the evolution of the
anus—or in some species, the cloaca—is
not well understood, as discussed in a 2015
review paper with the spectacular title, “Getting
to the bottom of anal evolution”.
While the anus itself is linked to the evolution
of a digestive system, not all metazoans have
a designated anus.
The hydra gut has only one opening, which
means that the organism’s mouth has to pull
digestive double duty and open back up to
release the waste.
And how that system fits in with the evolution
of digestion overall is unclear.
Much like the evolution of sex, anuses are
a trait that appears and disappears in evolutionary
lineages, reflecting the fact that they might
be useful for some animals and less so for others.
The duality of the hydra’s mouth seems to
be working out great for them after all.
But having a digestive system with a distinct
entrance and exit is pretty handy too.
For one, it’s just a little less disgusting.
But it also keeps food flowing in one direction.
And that means animals like the tardigrade
and us don’t have to wait to finish digesting
to eat more food.
That would be annoying.
We just get to keep eating, all thanks to
that evolutionary mystery that is the anus.
In the end though, anus or not, everybody
poops.
Food, after all, might be one of life’s
great pleasures, but all good things must
come to an end.
And perhaps, with the microcosmos, we can
find some pleasure in that as well.
And that is the conclusion of our journey through
the hind end of the microcosmos.
It was beautiful, it was gross.
And I hope, most of all, that unlike the nutrients
these organisms were getting rid of, this
video was not a waste.
So, thank you for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Before we go, we’d also like to say thank
you to each and every one of our Patrons.
Some of their names are on the screen right
now, and these are the people that make this
channel, and videos like this, possible and
for that we are so grateful.
If you’d like to become one of them, you
can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
And if you’d like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram, and if you’d
like to see more from us, there’s probably
a subscribe button somewhere nearby.